hello and welcome to part three of our
tkinter tutorial series in python 3.
where we left off we made our window
and in fact we can just go ahead and pop
it up made our window here
a simple gui window we can resize it we
can close it we can click on this button
but we can't it's not doing anything so
we want to have some sort of event
handling ability
so close this
and what we're going to want to do here
is we say
button we give it you know self which
could be bajoomba text equals quit
but then there's another parameter here
that we can add in and we can say
command and basically what command is is
what do we want to
happen right when we when someone clicks
on this button when this button is like
activated what do we want to happen well
what we might want to happen is the
following so self dot and then we're
going to call it client underscore exit
okay now client exit actually has no
um
doesn't exist yet so that's not
something that's you know built into
decanter or anything like that so we
define client exits so it could have
been called really anything we wanted so
now what we're going to do is same you
know in our oops
in our window class here
in our window class we have you know all
these functions and stuff so now we can
do is we can come down here
and we can define a new function
now
this function will say define client
underscore exit and then we'll say self
and we'll just leave the parameters for
now and just as a quick aside um i've
been getting some comments on one of my
other series entirely
and
the
the comment was that we're referencing
functions before they've been defined
and so some people have been having
trouble because they're trying to
reference their it's like throwing an
error saying you know this hasn't been
defined yet and you're trying to
reference it
uh
and so they're saying that in the in the
code it was for a pie game tutorial
series and in the code it's basically
something like this where we're
referencing self.client exit before
we're actually at self or we're at
client exit right so we're referencing
this function before it even exists and
then we did it again up here right and
we kept doing it
that's not against the rules of python
because right here we're just defining
functions and so functions are kind of
like
low you're going to envision you know
functions aren't really loaded until
maybe the very end or it's hard for me
to explain how why this is okay it's
basically acceptable because
a definition of a function is not a
running so when you define a function
it's not being run it's just being
defined and so
when it really matters is when you call
the function to be executed it's going
to say
okay it's go as we load this function in
it's going to you know tell p or python
is going to be like okay so we've got
this quit button it's a button when it's
clicked we need to reference client exit
but it's not trying to reference client
exit right at that moment it's it's just
storing the memory like what does it
need to do
with that function so right now
putting self.client exit before the
function client.exit that's totally fine
that's not actually we're not reference
i mean we are sort of you know in theory
referencing it before it's been defined
but we're not actually calling it before
it's been defined we're just storing it
to memory so
a little bit different there so
if at the same time if like above class
window let's say we called
uh you know window dot
in it
window like that okay if we did
something like that then yes we would be
defining um the principles because we're
calling first of all class window before
it's been defined but also init window
before it's been defined we're calling
it to execution and we can't so just as
a quick side not really quick but um
needed to be covered because like i said
some people were getting really confused
about that in the pi game tutorial
series and maybe some people are getting
confused about it now python is a
scripting language so it will go line by
line but it's only going to execute
something that you're asking it to
execute so
anyway moving along
so client x itself
actually can be very basic we can say
client x itself
and all we really need to do is just
exit okay so we can call just this exit
function it's a built-in
uh function into python
so with that uh we can do this
and so again quit button it's a button
it's text says quit
and the command for it is self.client
underscore exit so when we click on the
button it's going to run that function
so it comes down here it says client
exit what do we do exit done so we can
save that and we can run it
and up pops are gooey and we can hit
quit and just for the record this pops
up the program is still running do you
mind sure you want to kill it we do so
we'll hit okay and that's that's fine
okay so that is um some button or some
error handling will you go away that is
um
not error handling event handling
uh with tkinter obviously we can make
this much more complex so in this sense
all the button did was run client exit
and all client exit did was exit now you
can kind of foresee in the future some
of these buttons might do some more
fancy things than just that
but that's basically how you you would
handle it okay
so if anybody has any questions or
comments regarding this video as as far
as maybe what i was talking you can also
talk about uh
referencing it before it's been defined
if you if you're still confused about
that but if anybody else has any
questions about whatever uh feel free to
leave those below as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time